DOZENS OF POLITICIANS AND
CANDIDATES HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
THE MONTHS LEADING UP TO THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
CNN'S MATT RIVERS LIVE FOR US IN
MEXICO CITY.
LOOK.
THIS IS BRUTAL STUFF, MATT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
GOING UP TO WHAT WILL BE THE
LARGEST OVERALL ELECTIONS IN
MEXICO'S HISTORY, IT'S CLEAR
THAT THESE ELECTIONS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ESCAPE THE VIOLENCE THAT
SO OFTEN PLAGUES THIS COUNTRY.
HERE IS ABEL, A CANDIDATE FOR
LOCAL OFFICE.
CRIME WAS HIS NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
BUT JUST ONE DAY AFTER FILMING
THIS AD HE WAS DEAD, SHOT AND
KILLED IN BROAD DAYLIGHT ON A
BUSY STREET WHILE HANDING OUT
CAMPAIGN FLYERS.
STATE AUTHORITIES SAY MURRIETA
WAS A TARGET.
THEY DON'T KNOW BY WHO THOUGH.
AT LEAST 87 CANDIDATES OR
POLITICIANS HAVE BEEN KILLED.
THEY'RE PART OF THE 564
POLITICIANS OR CANDIDATES
OVERALL THAT HAVE BEEN TARGETED
BY SOME SORT OF CRIME RANGING
FROM MURDER TO ASSAULT TO
THREATS, THE FIRM SAYS.
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS IT BELIEVES
BOTH NUMBERS ARE FAR LOWER,
THOUGH, THEY DON'T SAY HOW THEY
TALLY THEIR NUMBERS, BUT THEY
ADMIT IT'S A PROBLEM.
IT'S A DIFFICULT TIME FOR THESE
CAMPAIGNS, SAYS, MEXICO'S
PRESIDENT.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP PROTECTING
THEM.
THOUGH MEXICO HAS FAILED IN
PROTECTING ITS CANDIDATES.
THIS YEAR IS PARTICULARLY BAD.
>> I DO THINK THIS IS GOING TO
BE CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
VIOLENT ELECTIONS IN MEXICAN
HISTORY.
>> Reporter: SECURITY EXPERTS
SAY POLITICIANS ARE KILLED FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS, BUT IT MOST
OFTEN INVOLVED ORGANIZED CRIME.
IN MANY CASES SHE SAYS CRIMINAL
GROUPS WANT THEIR PREFERRED
CANDIDATE IN OFFICE, SO THEY
MIGHT TARGET OTHERS THEY DON'T
LIKE, ESPECIALLY CANDIDATES WHO
MAKE CRIME A CENTERPIECE OF
THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
>> CANDIDATES THAT TALK THE WAY
ABEL MURRIETA SPEAK CLEARLY ARE
GOING TO RUN BIGGER RISKS.
>> Reporter: MURRIETA WAS KNOWN
FOR TARGETING DRUG AND CAR TELL
GROUPS.
AS A LAWYER, HE WAS KNOWN FOR
REPRESENTING AN OUTSPOKEN FAMILY
WHO HAD DUAL CITIZENSHIP WHEN
THEY LOST NINE OF THEIR MEMBERS.
THERE WAS A TWEET AFTER MURRIETA
WAS KILLED.
HE SAID, THEY KILLED MY
DEFENDER.
WHAT DO WE CALL THIS?
RULE OF LAW?
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE WAS KILLED
BECAUSE OF HIS OPPOSITION TO THE
CAR TELL?
>> YES.
HE WAS ALWAYS EXPOSED THEM.
TO ME, HE DIED A MARTYR.
>> THE VICTIM SEEMS TO KNOW HE
WAS AT RISK SAYING THIS A FEW
DAYS BEFORE HE DIED.
HE WENT ON TO SAY THE STREETS
BELONGED TO THE PEOPLE, NOT THE
CRIMINALS.
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE SHOWED UP
TO HIS FUNERAL.
THEY GAVE HIM A STANDING OVATION
AS HIS COFFIN WAS LED OUT.
AND RIGHT AFTER OUR STORY
FINISHED UP LAST NIGHT AFTER WE
PUBLISHED IT, JOHN, WE GOT WORD
THAT A CANDIDATE FOR MAYOR IN A
SMALL TOWN IN A STATE, SHE HAD
BEEN GUNNED DOWN, KILLED AT HER
OWN CAMPAIGN EVENT THERE.
THAT MEANS AT LEAST 88
POLITICIANS HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
THIS ELECTION SEASON WITH ABOUT
TEN DAYS LEFT OF CAMPAIGNING TO
GO.
>> DID YOU SAY 88?
>> Reporter: 88 POLITICIANS
AND/OR CANDIDATES SINCE
CAMPAIGNING BEGAN LAST SEPTEMBER
HAVE BEEN KILLED.
AND KEEP IN MINE, THERE'S
ANOTHER TEN DAYS LEFT IN THE
CAMPAIGN SEASON, JOHN.
AND THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS OF
CAMPAIGN SEASON ARE GENERALLY
THE MOST VIOLENT.
>> THAT'S STUNNING.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE PRESIDENT SAY,
OH, WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT THE
CANDIDATES, THEY'RE CLEARLY NOT.
THEY'RE CLEARLY NOT.
IT ALMOST SUGGESTS A LEVEL OF
BUSINESS AS USUAL HERE.
>> Reporter: 100%.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT GOES BACK
DECADES.
WHAT IS ALSO A PART OF THIS,
LEVELS OF IMPUNITY IN MEXICO.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A COUNTRY
WHERE 95% OF CRIMES GO UNSOLVED.
ONLY 0.3% OF CRIMES LIKE THIS,
PROSECUTORS PRESENT CHARGES
EVENTUALLY IN THESE CASES.
SO NOT ONLY IS THE GOVERNMENT
NOT PROTECTING THESE CANDIDATES,
BUT IN THE MAJORITY OF CASES,
THEY'RE NOT PROSECUTING ANYONE
FOR THESE CRIMES.
>> TALK ABOUT A BARRIER TO
ENTRY, TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT